I feel like you need to start the show
with that expression just lay hey
everyone its megabit where I play old
games with old friends on Fridays
because I don't have anything better to
do and and it's also our jobs and it's
our job which is great believe that or
not so today we're playing metal
warriors yeah yeah yeahs got titanfall
coming up pretty soon big thing I'm in
that game is you know you got these big
mex you jump in you jump out you fight
inside or outside of them and that's
exactly what you do at metal warriors
this is a game made by lucasarts came
out around towards the end of the Super
Nintendo and max I know you have some
experience playing this back in the day
yeah metal warriors came out April 95
but I didn't discover until I was in
college back when I was sort of i was on
the wrong side of the law with all my
super nintendo roms but you definitely
remembered that release date you said i
remember this game that came out of
april well that might have been because
i was looking at wikipedia ooo let's
jump in here we'll go ahead and start
with some one player this game also has
a fantastic two player head to head both
at we might see a little bit of later on
oh but but the intro i think is yeah
we're gonna show up right now because
you guys need to see this intro so good
for a game made by an American company
this is one of the best Japanese intros
ever I know right I can have to get the
fins so this game only came out in
America as well never made it to Europe
never made it to Japan to sing and it's
inspired by a series of games that the
assault suit series okay is that what
like what it's like the entirety of its
called because I know there's there's a
salt suit cyber nater and stuff well
seven eight ER with a cyber Nader is
assault suits vulcain i want to say
campaign but we got it yeah so cyber
Nader is a super nintendo game that we
got that's very similar to this came out
a couple years earlier also published by
but made by completely different peak
teams in different countries yeah you
want to see some titanfall stuff look
yeah what we're playing today dude any
boo boo boo boo boo and you could
totally there's gonna be some people up
here and you can titanfall these people
omx for coming talking about Titans I'm
gonna get my time boo boo boo boo move
standby for titanfall and there's a
truck titan truck so you can you've got
your boosters you can jump you've got a
shield will protect me from these little
dudes down here it was gonna get those
guys and then you've got a got sword
which as much as I'd like to you can't
use it while in the air so I'm gonna try
to remember you can't do that and then
the Y button sort of puts down this
little that's a shield I think yeah it's
like a stationary shield instead of just
having this one you hold for yourself um
and there's nothing up there selective
on but yeah so you can see other
people's max and those mechs have
different abilities yeah there's a bunch
of different Mecca it's a lot different
ability I think we'll see I think I'll
get one after i finish this first stage
you pick up a new mech early on but as
you saw there you can also blow up other
people's necks before they get into them
this game as you can see it has a lot of
little hidden areas so like weapon
upgrades and other max you can find and
I think lives as well I mean there was a
little health pick up down there that I
just thought I'd just picked up
something that's really cool is that
this game sort of does the I don't I
guess we'd know it is like the dead
space trick where there's very as you
can see this real minimum like huh door
you I the way you tell when your mech is
damaged
is it will start to turn it will start
to dis a trait it'll turn black and
white yeah it'll lose its color so the
closer you get to complete black and
white the closer you are guys let's go
tonight okay he's been trapped in there
all week he's like look eventually
somebody's gonna come down and I'm gonna
shoot the [ __ ] that I'm gonna be so
ready for any second now oh come on
won't even see me coming okay got rescue
this is you know this guy thank you
Thanks oh dear how this oh you're asking
guy you meet you as well shield yourself
like it not every day you go but yeah
the swords really powerful but again you
can only use it while on the ground
lucasarts always flexing their love for
the lightsaber mr. and cooperation come
play titanfall I know stand by for time
there's an athlete oh oh and I'll be
outta twisty bullets I guess it's really
more of like a drop shot shot I'll see
ya I don't think you can beat shield in
the area which is awful yeah I think
you're gonna pick up another backer
yeah these bazooka guys are the biggest
jerks you have to fly them in not it's
not happening I by flat than me I get
your guy out you mean titanfall of them
yeah yes time hologram are you gonna
pick up at four it's so easy hey God Oh
metal war you're such a tease and look
now it's gonna go away Oh is like you
totally did that wrong whoa boy whoa
oops I know and then you land on the
thing so not only do you when you land
on top of a mine folder the mine holder
explode go away images you and then the
minus deployed which also hits you and
damages ya see your missile they just go
away the game is like we gave you these
missiles we expected you to use them
look now we're in a strong where the
gift God gave you yeah who's your things
user your I think you have the antigrav
item on r1 l1 l1 ya see dope now you're
upside down what know that was a thing
whoa this dude's like I'm prepared i'm
prepared ok what is happening why are
you doing man I was the one shooting now
he is the one who is shooting imac see
what i see you can dash away that's so
great because you see the enemy in the
game you're like man those powers are so
cool he's dashing everywhere in his
robot looks on her really write you
another one out apparently easy please
enjoy you are the easiest let me play is
the bad guy I'm a happy camper kept the
sweet Mack plays here in the background
you can see where they put oh that thing
is totally a shield okay good no see
titanfall right there you've got a
shield that absorbs projectiles
titanfall ahead of its time
got all these mines I know them I'm
telling you see look and all my god no
I'm out a bunch of Mines and then you
try to run away oh oh that is so that is
so good design because they drop you in
there there's the guy with the cannon
after you've gone through two floors
mine's a guy with a cannon and then
there's this big open space to the left
and select just run to his left oh yeah
it did draw them dead pit full of mines
after running through a bunch of other
mind the rule is just don't go there
just don't just avoid going there that
game came out i want to say 98,000 baby
just hack this thing real quick babe
done this one actually I think it's a
bit of a downgrade from the mech we
start with but it's fun oh I didn't mean
a good oh oh that's gonna come back to
haunt later on you are the literal worse
I'm aware but look I've got the super
scoot yep super scoot nothing beats the
super scoot oh wait no oh I keep doing
this okay keep shooting myself in the
foot alright so there's gonna be is
gonna be a beginning worst thing ever
this guy do you just shut up guy by as
well in this suit as I was in the
original you just sort of fall slowly
I'm the super skirt suit the super scoot
dude come on
I'm just gonna have to
oh it's an alien
that's probably my best that's bad you
don't get shield here we go here we go
it's like he's just killing him back oh
man okay what are you doing you had I
know I had that whole scenario no no I
forgot to those only bad things over
there I wanted to retreat to the to the
left like the game wants you to I can
punish you okay you're just getting shot
for line and I can't fly up you can't
put up a shield bailing I'm bailing here
we go all right nobody pay attention to
me nothing to see here oh wow they
actually not oh I guess I can't you get
damaged them they can't damage you yeah
no harm no foul as it were the science
is down there having a friggin party
though woot yeah we're doing societies
man formulas guy the horn shoes like hey
you guys want hang out we have like no
no no oh no cool it's cool man just
could you just leave that a newsie yeah
we're parties yeah any people already
thought it was like mostly for the
scientists we didn't know you were gonna
come to UM the way the timer works it's
just gonna ok well there go my arms oh
wait a minute ok no don't go over there
and I'm gonna shut up shut up you shut
up I think the one of the mech suits may
have respond if you like me far enough
away hey talk about respawn in my right
Oh step back Oh integration what's in
the bar maybe I can ok ok I'm what if
you get a new mech e won't need it I'm
gonna try shot if you'll shut up I'm
gonna try to get some health where I
come from them's fightin words my friend
progress let's break up the scientist
party
let's try lemon follow the signs go home
you got titanfall again oh wow wow wow
no that puts me in a repo fee crap
situation yes I would say get off get up
get out of it up at the top first of all
I'm gonna kill these dudes they can just
eat addy but get out of it don't get out
of it there get no I'm gonna kill him
I'm gonna kill them oh no no see he's
gonna you did I just what i told you
that dick I remind you that was gonna
happen to that dick come from came out a
little up that come out of the walls Oh
folks we were gonna beat this stage ok
I've got this I've got this you guys or
suggested that I will whip him there you
go captain cannon got pushed back a
little bit
okay so dumb max max max go down to shut
I got it done you've done they are
destroying the core generator shut up
dude begins I can see his foot up there
come on they're not I'll I'm to core
generators intact dude I'm working off
stop it stop it oh no look sacrifices
had to be made they were strong core
generators Peter just but you also need
to deal with survival okay no I'm inside
getting his go shoot shoot that guy he's
honest I lost my bag guys get that I got
home gotta get to the [ __ ] car man great
job stone that's how you Sylvester a
situation oh that [ __ ] just got Stallone
Wow get it I didn't even oh hey I'm
flying the ship we're getting out of
here where do you want me to take it
where did it say to take it I cut this
matter okay follow your heart thank ya
yeah what's up buddy we have 15 minutes
you wanted to do ya head head let's try
a little head-to-head or let's hopefully
this controller is not busted your
control it might be a little weird the Y
and B buttons are a little weird it's
figure out so you have the havoc have it
was the crappy one with a whip and the
it's basically the sugar scoot the sugar
submit warrior in universe it's the John
Carlin I'm not getting ready to worry
but yeah so this is the big guy we were
just using yeah yeah he's got the
flamethrower there which is real
vol tastic fantastic and then the Nitro
i think is our standard our standard
bearer yes oh damn yeah it's really
gonna be a real world roller I'm till
it's all XNA for you alright so I've got
I can't even jump I've got a net and I
got this thing going on oh no I can't
jump oh holy cow I working what is going
on my gosh your controller so what I
can't do anything you have to come to me
I can't jump what shoot oh my i have to
walk along the wall so I'm headed your
way okay enemy unit to the right enemy
unit is a baby chick better neither
netic oh my god where are you I'm like
in that I'm basically in the middle or
I'm at the bottom oh there you are I'm
right above you alright alright I'm
coming to get you coming to get you
which way where's your Mick
no done that yeah also I'm really fast
as hell now what what is your issue so
parents one of my next powers that I can
disappear just animal you can still hit
me but I just you just can't see no you
can't see me can't you can't hit what
you can't see I'm a spooky spider yeah
all these max you find Wu you find in
the course of the campaign um and use
them on different stages and so cool all
right let's do let's pick different
suits hey buddy whoo no yeah come here
oh this attack only shoots down and this
attack on the shoot go wrong I want to
get above you let me get buggy Oh stab
step attack
this is now you must have some sort of
like oh yeah you know top and just
drilling hi buddy I'm gettin up tips to
elevator with you
so good so good riveting riveting got
this all right good anti grab a spider
oh no all right that proves it i'm
better at video games in maximum icky
sticky made mistakes were made all right
we're gonna sign off guys yeah yeah
thanks for watching megabit as always
we're here every friday at 11am pacific
standard time but every other day of the
week we also have another show step
tuned in also at 11 and don't forget
about the lobby on tuesdays at two p.m.
yeah fact I'm alright thanks for
watching everybody I'm Peter Brown I'm
Maxwell McGee take care
you